la présentation du projet de loi avec
aubry qui était prévu pour le début du
mois de mars est bien pourrait être
reporté c'est quasiment certain
ce projet qui fait couler beaucoup
d'encre et qui attire énormément et bien
de critiques c'est avec marielle de
sarnez euro députée et vice-présidente
du modem qu'on en parle ce matin
alors vous trouvez
est normal qu'on reporte sur l'examen du
projet de loi la vérité ça m'étonne pas
plus que ça parce que je trouve il ya
deux cadeaux question qui se poserait
j'ai le sentiment depuis le début que le
texte était on va dire improvisé mais
que tout ça se faisait dans une espèce
de précipitation sans concertation
écoutez on doit réformer le marché du
travail on doit la léger on doit le
simplifier on doit prendre en question
la question des heures supplémentaires
on doit prendre la question en la
question des été contraint d année mais
tout ça se regarde mais ça doit être
bien inspiré c'est à dire les choses
bien
pas de façon improvisée bas par exemple
les heures supplémentaires moi je suis
pour que les salariés continuent à avoir
une prime qui soient fondées qui soit
importante mais que par contre elle soit
neutre pour l'employeur c'est parce
qu'on était prévu plutôt que de regarder
les questions de licenciement de
prud'hommes est ce qu'il faudrait pas
regardé aux joues un jour un jour la
question du contrat unique comme ça a
été fait exactement la liste centriste
oui c'est plutôt une bonne chose de
laisser la liberté aux entreprises il
faut réformer mais il faut réformer bien
c'est la méthode de manière inspirée
il faut que les le contenu soit subtil
et intelligent et pertinents j'ai le
sentiment que la direction globale
n'était pas mauvaise mais qu'ils avaient
sur plusieurs points des points sur
lesquels nous pouvions avoir des
différences ça c'est la première chose
et deuxième chose on voit bien que ya
pas de majorité à gauche pour ce texte
on voit bien qu'il ya même une division
faune entreprise publique préconise à
dire se substituer justement une partie
mais vous savez quand vous voulez
vraiment réformer et au fond c'est ça la
question pour le pays pour quand vous
voulez vraiment réformer
vous vous y prenez pas comme ça vous
tout d'un coup brutalement sur la table
un projet c'est trop tard sans
préparation sans concertation dans un
timing oui bien sûr que c'est tardif
bah ça aurait été mieux au début du
quinquennat d'avoir une politique de
réformes d'ailleurs réforme notons le au
passage qui n'avait pas été fait par les
précédents locataires de l'elysée oui
donc oui bien sûr qu'il faut corriger
notre code du travail françois bayrou ne
cesse de montrer ce code qui est
extrêmement que trois jours plus de 3000
pages
ce n'est pas raisonnable mais si on veut
vraiment réformer il faut pas s'y
prendre de cette manière
je suis pas étonné qu'il reculait
pourtant vous avez des postes à des amis
de droite et centristes notamment
dominique reynié qui poussent à la roue
justement pour et bien que ce texte soit
examiné que ce texte soit voté un bon
texte ils ont lancé une pétition
je ne sais pas si le texte est si bon
que ça je pense que la direction de leur
bal pas voter vous moi je l'arrêté a
indiqué je leur ai demandé vous l'auriez
vendée je pense par exemple sur les
heures supplémentaires que oui il faut
que les salariés continuent à percevoir
des heures supplémentaires qui soit
intéressante pour eux mais il faut les
rendre neutre pour l'employeur c'était
pas prévu dans le texte
je pense qu'on peut avancer vers un
contrat de travail unique pour les
futurs contrats de travail pas pour les
contrats de travail existants que cette
question ait même pas abordé dans le
texte
donc oui avec des choses à ce niveau
légal général primaire à droite sont
quasiment tous pour abandonner les 35
heures c'est votre cas je pense que si
on a des heures supplémentaires qui soit
neutre pour l'employeur c'est une façon
fond de les rendre intéressante pour les
salariés notre nation reste qu'à écouter
je ne sais pas si c'est absolument
nécessaire je pense qu'on a des leviers
et des outils pour avancer autrement
alors il ya eu une surprise quand même
grave ce texte cet avant projet de loi a
été présenté ma belle connerie on s'est
dit mais pourquoi hollande et valse
sorte ça maintenant
ça vous a étonné aussi c'est un coup
politique je pense que valls veut voilà
mettre son empreinte mais j'y joue bien
je vois c'est hollande
j'ai peur qu'on soit dans un jeu de
postures sais quoi je postule le jeu de
postures si vous allez voir ce que vous
allez voir je suis un réformateur etc
mais qui comme valls et puis l'on dit 10
derrière non non non quand même faut
faire attention il faut que le texte
soit plus équilibrée les ministres
importants du gouvernement
le jour où le projet sorte 10 à 7 un
texte qui est déséquilibré jouer une
carte personnelle voir écouter quand on
n'est pas capable 1-2 convainquent déjà
son propre gouvernement
mais le texte va dans la bonne direction
de qu'on n'a même pas été en capacité de
négocier avec les syndicats dits
réformistes réformateurs et qu'on a la
cfdt au fond qui est opposée au texte
moi je me pose des questions et ce qui
n'a pas été trop vite est-ce que ça a
vraiment été bien préparé il a une
ambition présidentielle à votre avis
valls je pense que il se sent
aujourd'hui avec un peu coincé au fond
et qu'on est déjà dans la question de
l'après hollande etc ça et donc ça ça
implique évidemment ville pour gagner ma
vie aussi justement ce texte on verra là
visiblement il recule pas étudié les
reculs ouais hein donc après nous avoir
fait voilà on y va on y va on réforme et
puis avoir quelques parlementaires de
droite qui disent on est là on est là on
est là visiblement on voit bien que tout
ça ici sont pas bien martine aubry qui
est un désaccord avec ce texte dit trop
c'est trop est-ce que vous pensez que le
ps peut exploser
mais j'en suis presque à penser qu'une
recomposition de ce point de vue là
serait pas inutile pour le pays parce
qu'au fond on a un parti pourquoi ils
restent ensemble finalement peut-être
parce que il ya des places parce qu'il
ya des professionnels parce qu'il ya des
élections intermédiaires parce que etc
mais au fond on voit bien que il va
falloir faire bouger tout ça est que si
on veut réformer le pays il va falloir
qu'on travaille les uns les autres à
avoir des majorités linge à grâce au
bout mais il faudrait encore faudrait-il
que le premier ministre actuel travaille
différemment c'est à dire que poser un
texte sur la table et dire maintenant
voter de tous ceux qui sont sur leur
accord pour que sur le fond sur le fond
le valse de la primaire c'est un wagon
avec lequel moi je me sens pas très très
loin vous voyez bien emmanuel macron
c'est la même chose
tout ça est pas très loin non plus des
républicains qui peuvent être
réformateur oui ça fait 30 ans qu'on ne
réforme pas la france qu'on réforme pas
le pays
trente ans qu'on est à la traîne par
rapport à d'autres grands pays européens
par exemple comme l'allemagne c'est
qu'il ya des fondamentaux dans la vie
politique qui ne fonctionne pas il
pourrait y avoir un grand pôle centriste
avec des 100 plus de six mois doit
rester chez lui
c'est très important les partis de
droite de droite républicaine
il y a le centre avec françois bayrou il
ya des réformateurs au centre gauche et
à gauche
je crois qu'il faut qu'ils s'assument
qu'il s'assume clairement est ce qu'il y
aura du travail à faire ensemble dans
deux ans au moment de l'alternance je
crois que oui le centre françois bayrou
mais vous oubliez un peu vite quand même
lui dei que je christophe lagarde du mal
à suivre en ce moment un rat ben oui
donc pour les français c'est simple il
ya au fond une personnalité qui
représente le centre
c'est françois bayrou sentinelle ça oui
et bayrou
maintenant il est revenu à droite alors
on avait compris qu'il avait voté pour
françois hollande en 2012 nous n'avons
pas voté pour nicolas sarkozy ça c'est
tout à fait donc vous avez voté
procureur à ouvrir le débat si vous
voulez ce bilan nicolas savoir si je
pense pas que c'était un bon bilan ce
qu'il faut un candidat du centre à la
primaire de la droite mais la primaire
de la droite elle est faite justement
vous venez de le dire pour la droite
moi je ne suis pas de droite et je suis
assez heureuse de me tenir à l'écart de
tout cela parce que plus les jours
passent plus les candidats se rajoute au
fond moi vous savez je suis un peu
sceptique ça la primaire du jeu je vais
quand même
fillon juppé le maire sarkozy sont pas
tous déclarés mais écoutez on va arriver
qu'ils aient une douzaine de villes
savez très bien que nous nous continuons
à dire ce que nous pensons utile pour la
france et c'est pas la question de la
primaire c'est qu'est ce qui est utile
pour le pays
qu'est ce qui fera que la présidentielle
dans deux ans dans 15 mois sera réussi
il faudra un président rassembleur qui
aille au delà de sa majorité ou en tous
les cas qui est une majorité plus large
pour agir pour le bien du pays et de
l'europe dont nous n'avons pas parlé
qu'on soit en france forte
vous n'aurez pas une robe force que
françois bayrou peut-être un nord le
ministre donnant le pronom mini sera le
chef de la majorité parlementaire est
encore bien comme ça mais françois
bayrou jouera un rôle jouera pas le
temps de bien sûr pas écoutés nous
sommes toujours au fond en
responsabilité pour faire évoluer le
pays dans le bon sens
l'accueil de françois hollande par les
éleveurs notamment qui était très en
colère au salon de l'agriculture
ça vous a choqué très chahutées oui
c'est ok je sais jamais comme ça qu'on
dialogue
en même temps je crois qu'il n'ya une
colère qui monte
ils se sentent au fond abandonnés par
leur pays
les agriculteurs abandonnés par la
france et c'est vrai que je trouve que
la france doit réinvestir une position
politique à bruxelles qu'elle a perdu de
vue depuis plusieurs années et hollande
il est pas un peu abordé aussi à sa
majorité
complet
isolé je trouve qu'on est dans le trio
des médecins on est dans un délitement
du pouvoir délitement du pouvoir dans un
délitement du pouvoir dans un délitement
de la gouvernance et ce à un moment où
jamais les défis n'ont été silhouette si
nombreux base est ce que ça peut tenir
jusqu'en 2017
je le sens m je ne le savais pas je ne
sais pas c'est à dire c'est à dire
peut-être que le président peut je ne
sais pas dissoudre changer de premier
ministre
enfin référendum je pas fait tout ça ce
sont les leviers les outils
institutionnels qu'il a mais il peut
aussi ne rien se passer c'est à dire
qu'on peut continuer dans un délitement
nous sommes plus en plus lourd dans une
des compositions de plus en plus lourdes
ce qui fait que oui vraiment à ce moment
là le rendez vous de l'élection
présidentielle prochaine sera cruciale
moi je veux le réussir j'en reprends le
ministre c'est possible alors mais on
verra c'est hollande qui qui peut le
faire moi je ne sais pas ce qu'il a en
tête
aujourd'hui mais c'est vrai que le
pouvoir est isolé il est divisé en son
sein il n'y a pas de boussole clair ce
qu'on voit bien que ça tire dans deux
sens totalement opposées qui a une vraie
fracture de la gauche tous ah bah c'est
pas très bon pour le pays il ya treize
mois d'une élection présidentielle ou
quatorze mois on peut faire un
référendum on peut dissoudre
je crois que tout ça ce sont des outils
institutionnels que président a à sa
portée je ne suis pas sûr que ça
changera sensiblement le climat c'était
le talk de marielle de sarnez de sarnez
qui estime que le l'avant-projet de loi
de madame mêmes conneries était
peut-être un peu précipitée que dans le
détail il fallait certainement faire
davantage de dialogue pousser davantage
le dialogue
ilic le pays quand même en train de se
déliter et qu' elle ne sait pas si on
peut continuer comme ça jusqu'à
l'élection présidentielle de 2017
ce qui est sûr c'est que si ça continue
bien l'élection présidentielle de 2017
sera tout à fait capital et elle nous
dit aussi que et bien les gens de bonne
volonté du centre gauche du centre droit
peuvent très bien en restant chacun chez
eux travailler ensemble merci
merci frère